and yeah is with us in North Carolina hi
Kenya
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how are y'all good how can we help good
I was calling because I have a question
I just got engaged in February and
where's the wedding next September
September squares 2021 why so long well
because I want to if I have a question
for my purposes I want to be sure that
we're I'm debt free one I'm sorry why
because I want to be better before we
get married why so that you do it
together or can't you do it together
after you're married
finish it up that's a great idea
yeah let's move it to this September
okay Dave you can't just move wedding
dates but can you how much debt does
your fiance have my fiance is actually
really great with his spending I don't
say he only has his car loan debt so I
would say well 19 okay and how much do
you have I have 12,000 and what do you
make I make 24,000 what's he make he
makes us about 32 all right I put all
that I'd put everything on hold save you
up a little money get married in
September this one and have you basic
simple wedding something under 10 grand
you can do that if y'all save like crazy
between now and then and then when
you're married let's get after it and
get let's get it all paid off
you may want to sell his car it's a wee
bit expensive but other than that you
got a plan here kiddo I don't believe in
waiting
to be out of debt to get married if
that's your only reason to wait yeah if
you're both on the same page and it
sounds like you're both on the same page
you're getting out of debt right that is
correct yes yeah
attendee do you have a big family I
don't okay well here's the thing can I
tell you something let let uncle Hogan
give you some guidance here this wedding
has nothing to do about the other people
okay
I'm not I don't I don't care about what
they think this is you all's day so so
many people end up spending 30 or 40
grand on this grand party for the whole
family and it's not about them
it's about you and your fiancee coming
together so you guys can do this on a
smaller scale and I agree with Dave you
could do it a lot sooner it's about what
you all are wanting but I love the idea
that you both have this mindset of
attacking debt and I want you to keep
that mindset together as you move
forward I'm gonna give you a wedding
gift I don't give you a financial piece
for you and your fiance and you guys go
through that as part of your pre
marriage counseling you got plenty of
time to do that between now and this
September and if I were in your shoes
that's what I would do I mean the
chances of me waiting 18 months to marry
Sharon Ramsey when I met her was zero
I woulda drugged heard of the alternate
about 30 seconds if I could've got away
with it but there was a six month
waiting period with Myers who couldn't
let her do it away there that's exactly
right because I had to talk into it as
friend she changed her mind but there
you go so but you know chances are
waiting around 18 months yeah it is you
know just for some kind of a financial
goal that's putting that's putting
things in the wrong order as long as
you're on the same page about the big
four which is in-laws kids religion and
money and if you're on the same page
about money by getting out of debt
that's the number one cause of divorce
and you got to sit down go through
financial peace as part of your pre
marriage counseling get some good
pre-marriage counseling and I personally
don't recommend waiting until you're out
of debt to get married there are people
that quote me as having said that I did
not say that ever in 30 years here on
the air but I do believe you must be on
the same you must be aligned in your in
your belief system yes
I mean if he's gonna stay in debt the
rest of his life or you're gonna spend
money like a princess the rest of your
life and he doesn't and he's a tightwad
and you're gonna have problems that's
running that's not with that I would
tell you to wait until you got that
straightened out that's a deal-breaker
but you guys are aligned you don't make
a lot of money you don't have a lot of
debt we gotta get your incomes up get
your careers moving
you're young you're just getting started
you're gonna do great yeah and do the
real premarital counseling not this
microwaveable thing where you you know
you go 20 minutes and the pastor's
office is not pre-marriage at is not I'm
telling you you need to dig in there are
assessments and tools and things you got
to do yeah yeah y'all Davis you know
simple system from from from my friend
dr. Leslie here it is a good system
which is a great one yeah good stuff
kiddo
hey you hang on Madison will pick up and
we'll give you your first wedding gift
because your weddings gonna be coming up
quicker now see what has happened here
you and me we are giving wedding advice
this is dangerous American jurist this
is that this is swerving outside your
lane I need to sign a waiver you do a
liability waiver deeply in or deeply in
the kimchi's order new business Dave
Ramsey now now that one would fail
that's a terrible idea
a bad idea you're right